klaus wer hat gewonnen
schwer zu sagen also ich muss wirklich
sagen wenn jemand der sich für politik
nicht richtig interessiert dazu geguckt
hat dann geht er gar nicht wählen also
sozusagen das sieben politiker so wenig
von sich selber preisgeben können durch
die choreografie aber dann auch den raum
nicht nutzen es zu tun ist ein weiterer
tiefpunkt sozusagen in diesem wahlkampf
jetzt sollen was aber positiv wenden
der sieger ist für mich markus söder
markus söder ist in meiner wahrnehmung
der einzige in dieser runde der in
kurzer zeit prägnant klar machen kann
dass er ein land führen könnte und
führen wollen würde und irgendwie ist in
manche einstellungen bei ihm auch klar
geworden was ist mit ihm macht das nicht
führen darf nämlich also das war war für
mich der größte eindruck mein mann meine
reihenfolge wäre ja ein 1 baerbock an
zwei linden an drei gewonnen wenn wir
uns gerade den kampf laschet gegen
scholz anschauen dass ein enges rennen
zwei bis drei prozentpunkte auseinander
in den verschiedenen umfragen wer konnte
da heute aus deiner sicht überzeugen gab
es da etwas ja keiner von den beiden auf
jeden fall also ich sehe es anders für
mich war lindner ganz weit vorne ich
fand ihn sehr informiert sehr
staatsmännisch also wenn es darum ging
er zum beispiel eine band zu gründen
dann wäre lindner für mich auf jeden
fall der erste kandidat immer ein poster
boy die strahlenden blauen augen er hat
immer ganz genau
die moderatoren angeschaut und ich
glaube dass er einfach der charmanteste
ist das muss man sagen dass konnte er
heute nicht so ausspielen wie sonst ich
war mal mit ihm auf einer veranstaltung
200 erfolgreiche unternehmerinnen lagen
ihm sofort zu füßen innerhalb von zwei
minuten hat er den ganzen raum
gequetscht das war heute nicht die
veranstaltung dafür weil es war eine der
traurigsten und spaßbefreite ssten
tv-debatten die ich je gesehen habe das
war wirklich so dass du denkst
macht es euch gar keinen spaß dieses
land zu regieren also das fand ich
eigentlich sehr sehr deprimierend
[Musik]